hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
[Musik]
ihr könnt euch heute auf einen richtig
schönen Abend freuen auf einen Wunder
wunderschönes Video was auch teilweise
ist sehr emotional ist denn wir gehen
heute gemeinsam nach yoursgard in die
Türkei dort gibt es nämlich ein kleines
Dorf das heißt checke Deck und wir haben
den Bürgermeister des Dorfes oder der
Stadt kennengelernt und der
Bürgermeister ist wirklich ein ganz
toller es seit drei Jahren schon im Amt
und setzt sich dort wirklich für
Frauenrechte ein also in einem Land in
dem teilweise noch sehr viel Tradition
und Kultur herrscht andererseits aber
auch sehr modern ist ist er wirklich
dort in der Türkei und leitet dieses
Dorf diese Stadt und es ist wunderschön
zu sehen wie er dort die Frauen
unterstützt er möchte nämlich dass
Frauen nicht einfach nur zu Hause sitzen
sondern dass sie sich frei entfalten
können dass sie arbeiten können vor
allem dass sie ihren Interessen
nachgehen können und unterstützt dort
deswegen die Fraueninitiative die hat
seine Frau gegründet Emine haben und sie
ist dort der Vorstand und die Frauen
dort sind wirklich der Hammer die sind
kreativ sie sind fleißig sie sind
wahnsinnig intelligent und sie haben
alle zusammengeschlossen und gesagt wir
wollen einfach was tolles tun wir wollen
etwas bewirken und was bewegen in Yozgat
gibt es ganz ganz viele Lavendelfelder
und wohl Lavendel wächst da riecht es
einfach unglaublich schön es ist ein
wunderschönes Gebirge dort wunderschöne
Felder und es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn
dort zu leben man muss aber auch dazu
sagen dass die Hausrat nicht gerade
dafür bekannt ist dass es eine
Touristengegend ist also wenn man so an
Urlaubsorte in der Türkei denkt denkt
man vielleicht nicht direkt an josegott
wenn man an Urlaubsgebiete denkt sondern
eher an Antalya oder dass sie der Alanya
da wo es schön warm ist oder wenn man
mal so ein Städtetrip machen will
vielleicht auch Istanbul Jungs gerade
ist aber auch eine richtig tolle Region
die noch eine ganz ganz tolle Natur hat
und der Bürgermeister dort möchte auch
dass sie ausgeht wirklich auch zu einem
Touristen Gebiet wird und Menschen von
aller Welt diese schöne Region
kennenlernen jedenfalls gibt's dort
diese Frauen Initiative diese Frauen
haben sich zusammengeschlossen es gibt
frühstücksgebiete es gibt Mittagessen es
gibt aber auch ganz ganz viele tolle
Produkte die sie zum Beispiel aus
Lavendel herstellen Kosmetik
Lebensmittel Zutaten
und diese Frauen die sind fleißig sind
tolle und kreative Ideen und sie haben
echt tolle Produkte hergestellt ihnen
fehlt aber an Marketing und natürlich an
Reichweite und da kommen wir ins Spiel
wir haben jetzt zum Bürgermeister gesagt
wir kommen euch besuchen wir zeigen den
Menschen da draußen einfach mal was ihr
alles Tolles macht was ihr bewegt und
wollen euch und vor allem die Frauen vor
Ort einfach unterstützen ihr könnt euch
übrigens noch auf eine ganz tolle
Überraschung freuen aber ich verrate
euch nicht zu viel jetzt lehnt euch am
besten erstmal zurück freut euch auf
einen wunderschönen Film auf tolle
Menschen die ihr gleich kennenlernen
werdet und vor allem auf einem
bezaubernde Natur
[Musik]
ja wir sind jetzt hier weil ich euch
unsere neue Kosmetik vorstellen möchte
wir waren ja letztes Jahr schon in
Sparta und haben dort unser eigenes
Rosenwasser hergestellt es war sehr geil
[Musik]
und wir haben uns jetzt überlegt was
können wir denn noch machen ihr wisst ja
ich erinnere mich ja recht gesund und
schaue immer was wir alles essen und
verzehren alles schön Bio soweit ist
eben auch geht auch bei den Kindern und
was immer auch ganz wichtig ist dass
eben nicht nur das was wir essen wichtig
ist für den Körper sondern auch das was
auf die Haut drauf kommt denn die Haut
das ist müsst ihr auch wissen einfach
unser größtes Organ und alles was auf
die Haut kommt praktisch in den Körper
mit rein und deswegen haben wir eine
Creme entwickelt die quasi aus
Naturkosmetik besteht die aus Zutaten
besteht die man wirklich auch essen kann
das zeige ich euch später auch da sind
wir auf die Idee gekommen weil wir uns
gedacht haben wir könnten doch unser
Rosenöl unser Rosenwasser verbinden mit
unserem Olivenöl was eben auch richtig
toll für die Haut ist und haben dann
gedacht dass wir nicht nur Rose
verwenden sondern eben auch orange hoch
seht ihr jetzt kommt der schon der ganze
Wind eben auch orange und auch Lavendel
und weil wir gerade hier in ihrer sind
jetzt ist nämlich gerade august und die
lavendelzeit ist jetzt im vollen Gange
sind wir hier auf den Lavendelfeldern
und werden gemeinsam jetzt erstmal
Lavendel später destillieren und dann
stellen wir unsere eigene Creme her und
das zeige ich euch jetzt gleich
[Musik]
Schatz
okay
Entgegner ist es wie lange ist das Ding
zwei Meter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt sind wir hier auf dem Lavendelfeld
und ich kann euch gar nicht beschreiben
wie schön es hier ist direkt am Wasser
ist es einfach der Hammer hier sind die
ganzen Hügel die ganzen Inseln voll mit
Lavendel und wir werden den jetzt hier
sammeln und zwar ist hier wichtig dass
man den Lavendel einfach schön mit einer
Schere wegschneidet genau ganz wichtig
ist dass man Lavendel nur zu ein Drittel
zurückschneiden am besten machen wir das
wenn man zu Hause Lavendel hat Ende Juli
scheint mir wirklich ein Drittel zurück
dann kommt er im Spätherbst kommt doch
noch mal und es ist ganz wichtig dass
man dann nicht ins Holz schneidet weil
wenn wir uns Holzschneider ist kann sein
dass er nicht mehr kommt ja und verhaft
zu Hause ist dann eben perfekt und dann
hat man zweimal im Jahr in lavendelte
und jetzt denkt ihr vielleicht okay wenn
ich zu Hause meine Lavendel züchten kann
sowie auch wir vor unserer Tür wäre mir
wirklich extrem viel Lavendel die
lavendelsträuchert die blühen regelrecht
und wirklich auch zweimal im Jahr und
eigentlich könntet ihr zu Hause auch
Lavendelöl selbst herstellen aber der
Aufwand dafür wäre einfach viel zu groß
weil man da eben diese dieses
destilliergerät braucht und da einfach
so ein wenig Ertrag rauskommt dass es
sich für zu Hause gar nicht lohnen würde
weil man da einfach viel zu viel Strom
und Energie dafür verbrauchen würde also
reden wir jetzt nicht zu lange sondern
pflücken den herrlich duftenden Lavendel
für euch Ela hast du auch schon was ich
habe hier auch schon guck mal gibst du
mir das was du hast schon den hier rein
ich trage es dann hoch
ja okay
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wird ja auch in der Kulinarik eingesetzt
nicht nur in der Kosmetik als zwar gut
für Körper Geist und Seele aber auch
kulinarisch wirklich ein top-erlebnis
denn man kann ja daraus Lavendel Tee
machen man kann Lavendel zum Würzen
verwenden man kann lavendelsirup
Lavendel Honig alles mögliche herstellen
man kann sie auch in Säckchen machen und
zwischen die Kleider Legenden das ist
ein ganz ganz natürlicher Duftstoff da
braucht die auch kein Weichspüler mehr
der einen guten Duft hat und es reicht
wirklich aus und es ist gut gegen Motten
das ist ganz ganz wichtig das hält auch
Ungeziefer genau denn für uns Menschen
ist der Lavendel Duft wirklich sehr
schön und sehr wohl und für Insekten
aller Art ist Lavendel Duft nämlich gar
nicht schön das heißt Insekten bleiben
einfach gut fern
ich weiß jetzt schon wer daheim überall
Lavendel ausstreut ist der Tolga
der macht sich ein ganzes Kopfkissen aus
Lavendel
schon der Wahnsinn wenn man überlegt
dass die Sträucher erstmal ein Jahr alt
sind wenn die jetzt erstmal drei für
fünf Jahre alt sind dann ist hier alles
voll mittlerweile Lavendel wächst halt
eben auch extrem gut
für euch gibt es jetzt hier an der
Stelle was zu gewinnen ich habe hier
schon eine fertige Lavendel Creme von
uns und die gibt's ja auch in der Sorte
orange und Rose und ihr könnt ein
komplettes kosmetikpaket von uns
gewinnen mit einem Olivenöl Paket wenn
ihr jetzt folgende Frage beantwortet es
sind eigentlich zwei Fragen denn zum
einen möchte ich von euch gerne wissen
wie heißt denn der Ort in dem der
Lavendel geerntet wird und ich meine
damit nicht Direktion gehabt sondern das
kleine Dörfchen wurde Bürgermeister auch
herkommt und dann würde ich ganz gerne
wissen welche Region welche Stadt oder
welches Dorf in der Türkei würdet ihr
denn gerne noch entdecken also wo soll
ich mit meinem Team als nächstes hin ist
es vielleicht Istanbul ist es Konya oder
es ist eine ganz andere Stadt oder
Region die ihr gerne sehen möchtet
schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare und
dann bekommt ihr ein schönes Set von uns
geschenkt und übrigens Latein
Ella ich erkläre dir mal noch was über
Lavendel
also Lavendel hat ja so einen tollen
Geruch ne und die alten Römer die
wussten das auch schon und Lavendel
kommt übrigens wahrscheinlich aus
Persien und früher bei den Römern hat
man Lavendel schon dafür verwendet um
sich zu reinigen also um sich zu waschen
Körper aber auch um die Kleidung zu
waschen und daher kommt auch der Name
Lavendel kommt nämlich von dem
lateinischen lavare was bedeutet das
Ella du schlaues Kind noch mal Ella das
habe ich ja eben erst erklärt
hat es jetzt einfach hast du das jetzt
abgeleitet ja sehr gut ja Lavendel komm
vom lavare
hast du noch Platz in deinem Sack
[Musik]
so schön hier meditativ und es macht so
viel Spaß mit den ganzen Frauen hier den
Lavendel zu pflücken und die haben auch
schon gesagt ihr macht auch richtig viel
Spaß vor allem ist es für sie eine
schöne Abwechslung weil einfach mal was
los ist hier
freuen sich richtig dass wir als
Kamerateam da sind kommt diese Frauen
gerne besuchen es ist wirklich toll die
sind ganz ganz herzlich hier ganz liebe
Menschen die verdienen hier mit ihren
Lebensunterhalt das ist was ganz tolles
und vor allem als Kollektiv als Frauen
dass sie hier zusammen Geschäft
aufgebaut haben alle zusammen und
verkaufen ihren Lavendel die verkaufen
ihr Hagebuttentee ihre Hagebutten das
ist ganz ganz toll und
das soll natürlich auch für
Arbeitsplätze in einer strukturschwachen
Region wo die Industrie nicht so ist und
es ist die einzige Einnahme schneller
die diese Frauen hier haben und das ist
unterstützenswert
[Musik]
ich habe den Blumenstrauß [ __ ]
der war umsonst
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt eine Auszeichnung
bekommen dass der Bürgermeister der
Stadt und er hat hier auch in den
letzten drei Jahren also erst seit drei
Jahren im Amt und in den letzten
zweieinhalb Jahren hat er hier einiges
vorangebracht und hat auch dafür gesorgt
dass sie wirklich auch eine Art
Tourismus entsteht dass hier Menschen
herkommen und die Menschen hier die hier
wirklich ganz ganz hart arbeiten eben
auch ein gutes Geld verdienen und sie
sorgen jetzt hier dafür dass eben alles
einfach ein bisschen schöner gemacht
wird und dass die Frauen hier vor allem
die haben nämlich so eine Frau
Initiative und hier ist wirklich Frauen
im Power Mensch denn die Frauen arbeiten
hier wirklich einen hohen Positionen
die die Emine haben zum Beispiel ist der
Vorstand von den ganzen Lebensmitteln
die hergestellt von der ganzen
Produktion es gibt ganz viele Frauen
hier die Frauenrechte machen uns
wirklich schön zu sehen das ist hier
alles trotz dass es sowas traditionelles
ist einfach so modern gedacht ist ich
habe die sekre
[Musik]
stolz macht dass ich als Frau vor allem
als Frau
eben auch so zur Welt sprechen und
deswegen hat sie mir eine Lampe gemacht
wo mein Name drauf steht mit meinem Logo
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und eins zwei drei
[Musik]
ich sag's euch ich fühle mich jetzt
schon zehn Jahre jünger weil ich die
ganze Zeit Lavendel rieche Lavendel um
mich herum habe und weiß das Lavendel
sehr gut für meine Haut ist ja hier
zeige ich euch jetzt ich habe jetzt hier
mein Lavendelöl
und zwar funktioniert das Ganze so dass
man den Lavendel also diese ganzen
Lavendelblüten einfach von den Rispen
abzupft das ganze dann eben in ein
Destillat Gefäß gibt und da wird das
ganze mit Wasserdampf dann so
destilliert das quasi Wasserdampf
entsteht das Lavendelöl trennt sich
davon der Wasserdampf kondensiert und
geht dann über einen Schlauch nach unten
und dann kann man später Wasser und Öl
einfach voneinander trennen und für 1
Liter Lavendelöl braucht man wirklich
starke und schreibe 120 Kilo
Lavendelblüten das sind bei uns 20 volle
Säcke und dann hat man einen Liter
und der Vorgang von der Lavendelblüte
zum Lavendelöl dauert acht Stunden
deswegen haben wir das hier jetzt heute
morgen schon gestartet und jetzt werden
wir mal unser kostbares Lavendelöl
abzapfen und das was übrig bleibt also
dieses Lavendel Wasser das Lavendel
Hydrolat das ist auch sehr wertvoll das
wird dann weiter verwendet für Kosmetika
zum Beispiel könnte man auch theoretisch
als lavendelwasser fürs Gesicht
verwenden man macht kolonia draus man
macht Desinfektionsmittel Seifen und so
weiter draußen Shampoo alles Mögliche
was man eben so mit Lavendel herstellen
möchte und ich habe jetzt hier zwar
unser Lavendelöl aber ich habe ja auch
noch die zwei anderen Sorten das heißt
Rose und Orange aber ich wollte euch das
einfach jetzt anhand des lavendel ist
zeigen ich zeige euch mal kurz die
Hauptbestandteile unserer Creme und das
sind wirklich alles Zutaten die man
wirklich auch essen kann das heißt die
Creme ist nicht nur für die Haut gut die
ist auch wirklich für euren Körper gut
und da sind jetzt wirklich keine
weiteren Stoffe drin die man nicht essen
kann also keine Parabene keine
künstlichen Duftstoffe kein Parfüm
wirklich rein gar nichts alles ganz
natürlich hauptbestandteil ist zum einen
unser Olivenöl das machen wir auch
selbst dass das Olivenöl was es auch
eben zum Verzehr gibt und das sind ja
wirklich ganz viele Antioxidantien drin
und was viele nicht wissen Olivenöl ist
wirklich sehr sehr gut zur Haut pflegt
die Haut und hat ganz viele tolle
Vitamine enthalten und vor allem hat
Olivenöl sogar einen Sonnenschutzfaktor
muss man dazu sagen hier habe ich jetzt
noch ein bisschen share Butter dann
haben wir noch weitere ganz tolle Fette
die eben die Haut pflegen mit
Feuchtigkeit und Vitaminen versorgen und
dafür sorgen dass ihr alle schön und
lange jung bleibt wie zum Beispiel
Kokosöl ich habe ein Rizinusöl was ich
auch persönlich ganz gerne für Haut und
Haare verwende weil es bei den Haaren
zum einen gegen Haarausfall ist und eben
auch das Haarwachstum verstärkt z.B für
Augenbrauen oder Wimpern ganz gut
geeignet dann haben wir auch ein
Schwarzkümmelöl ich habe hier ein
Johanniskrautöl und das sind wirklich
alles ganz tolle Bestandteile und ich
würde sagen ich stelle jetzt hier mal
meine eigene Creme für euch her
[Musik]
ach Gott ist das süß meine Güte
und wie wird Mädel schon probieren
die ist noch nicht fertig die ist noch
lange nicht fertig guck die muss noch
homogener werden
echt gut jetzt ohne Witz wenn die
Konsistenz so schlecht schmeckt das gar
nicht schlecht
noch ein bisschen muss noch homogener
werden okay Mädels weiter rühren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in die Creme nee ich habe da schon
Lavendelöl drin mein Schatz habt ihr
einen Eis probieren
unintelligible reinmachen ja mach's da
rein Schatz so
frischen Löffel also wir wollen jetzt
nicht also die Creme ist nicht zum Essen
da die ist schon für die Haut aber wir
wollen nur zeigen dass man sie essen
kann also nur aus Zutaten
ich kenne natürlich schon
gut ne
also man sollte in der Küche benutzen
Ella Lavendel lavendel ist nämlich auch
zum Kochen
also aber das Brot wirklich nein wir
haben die Creme dafür entwickelt dass
ihr eure Haut damit pflegen könnt und
Komma zeig mal ganz genau dass sie mit
Menschen zu Hause haben als allererstes
wir werden sie probieren ich weiß jetzt
schon tut es nicht sie ist besser für
die Haut und die Orangencreme kann man
auch essen
Konsistenz ist richtig schön natürlich
wird sie bei uns maschinell hergestellt
im Labor damit Sie wirklich schön
homogen ist und dann kommt sie aus der
Tube nämlich richtig schön raus ich
zeige euch das mal
und da seht ihr jetzt richtig schön
das ist eine homogene Creme
ich finde es schön die zieht auch gut
ein und was für mich in der Küche
natürlich ganz wichtig ist ich bin ja
wirklich vielen der Küche und habe auch
ganz oft trockene Hände muss ich sagen
weil ich viel meine Hände waschen und
viel zubereitet und mich dann meine
Hände danach eincreme ist mir natürlich
auch wichtig dass ich eine Creme auf der
Haut habe die eben auch Lebensmittel
tauglich ist damit ich später die Creme
eben nicht im Hefeteig zum Beispiel drin
habe deswegen unsere schöne Handcreme
die auch komplett für den Körper
benutzen können eine Lippenpflege kommt
auch noch dazu und dann werden wir mal
schauen wohin unser Weg geht mit unserer
Naturkosmetik und wie gesagt Lavendel
orange und Rose ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat von der
Lavendel Ernte vom Creme herstellen und
natürlich auch vom Destillat und ja dann
würde ich jetzt sagen wir verweilen hier
noch ein wenig er schreibt mir gerne was
eure Lieblingsstelle hier im Video war
was ihr am schönsten fandet und falls
ihr mal in der Türkei ganz tollen Urlaub
machen wollt und einfach mal Natur pur
erleben wollt in Jungs gerade dann kommt
wirklich hierher es ist wunderschön hier
gibt's kleine Häuschen wo man einfach
als Unterkunft buchen kann hier kann man
craften gehen hier kann man die Natur
erleben Lavendelfelder genießen und
einfach die Menschen hier vor Ort
unterstützen denn die machen das hier
wirklich richtig schön
[Musik]
und Ella hat ihren Hut verloren
dann lass mich den Einstieg machen und
du machst es nimmt zurückschneiden
[Musik]
professionell arbeiten können oder
einmal jetzt passt alles jetzt müssen
auf die Wolke warten
ja genau
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
vielleicht mal was das für ein schöner
Arbeitsplatz ist hier an der Sonne und
duftet so gut ihr könntet auch auf einer
Mülldeponie arbeiten heute Nacht werde
ich gut schlafen
ich habe heute diese Rose für dich
möchtest du diese Rose von mir bekommen
nein
ich habe jetzt gehofft sie sagt Papa hat
welche habe ich echt gehofft kleine Maus
wenn ich deine Maske benutze gehen dann
meine Augenringe weg
der Vorgang bis man hier aus Lavendel
wow danke
das Lichter okay
[Musik]